Elon Musk is unbanning everyone first
Donald Trump is unbanned he has this
Twitter poll there's this really funny
news clip where a guy says it wasn't the
American people who voted it was Russia
they they it was them they got Trump
reinstated these people are starting to
realize that their narrative was fiction
and it was propped up by the machine and
now that regular people get to speak hey
how about that they don't actually like
the weird world you live in not just
Donald Trump though project Veritas is
back James Lindsay is back Marjorie
Taylor green is back but you know he's
not back Alex Jones so we got to talk
about all this Elon stuff because uh
look a lot of it's really really good
overwhelming net positive but Elon
musk's refusal to raise State Alex Jones
is making him look like a hypocrite and
I know Elon understands this so I kind
of can't believe him when he says oh
it's because I have no mercy for people
who exploit children in this way for
fame or whatever
Alex Jones was banned for making fun of
Oliver Darcy he wasn't banned for saying
anything about kids or anything like
that so what's Elon talking about well
let's talk about the pros and the cons
there's a whole bunch of news to break
down as it pertains to Twitter then of
course we have over in Arizona the
Attorney General is launching an
investigation into election
irregularities and the assistant A.G is
refusing to certify the election I have
no idea what YouTube thinks of that
YouTube
what no idea I don't know how do the
rules I have no idea so we'll talk about
it anyway so uh before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
if you would like to support our work
click that beautiful join us button sign
up and as a member you will help support
all of our journalists and you'll get
access to the exclusive uncensored
members only show we're gonna have one
of those coming up for you tonight
around 11 p.m so don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
Channel right now and share the video if
you're watching on YouTube take that URL
just post it everywhere you can word of
mouth is the is the best way to support
us and it helps us bypass the censorship
because sure enough we're already
getting people messaging us saying that
there are no notifications they're
having trouble finding the video so
surprise surprise but uh you know smash
that like button joining us today to
talk about all of this and more is
Darren Beatty
great to be here thanks for having me
who are you I'm the founder editor of a
great news site called
revolver.news which had just published a
really
um bombshell piece on the next FTX
Scandal which I hope will have a chance
to talk about yeah is that tether yes
there's been a lot of talk about tether
for a while but we'll definitely get
into that that sounds very interesting
and I'll also mention
uh the last episode we had you on was
our biggest episode we ever did for a
while until we had Joe Rogan and Alex
Jones at the same time but like come on
like having those two at the same time
you know that shouldn't count like
having you as a single guest and getting
it was like 2.4 million views or
something right you have to you have to
divide it in half first actually you
know what I can I can tell you this
actually with a live viewership and the
VOD stuff was put on Rumble it actually
is still the biggest there you go
because we had it like we had like 300K
so I think it's like if you were to add
the YouTube views from the day plus
Rumble it would be 200k more than the AJ
uh Rogan episode so how you count that's
how it's all how you count it's all you
can all right right on men thanks for
joining us and we're also hanging out
with Mary Morgan hello everyone I'm
sitting in Ian's seat tonight happy to
be here who are you I'm on pop culture
crisis oh yeah that's a short test
that's right so you should go subscribe
to that that's a great show I think so
too
you know what's another great show
.com uh anyway uh today I come here with
one simple message make Orwell fiction
again it's just getting too real out
there this is one of the shirts uh this
is the message on my shirt it's one of
the first shirts that we actually got
out there to the general public it's one
of the first ones that kind of went
viral uh and I'm wearing it today if you
want to wear it you could get it on the
best politicalshirts.com because you do
this is how you guys support me and my
efforts here so thank you so much for uh
having me Splurge back once again hello
Luke hello Mary good to have you guys
here are you okay with the fact that he
calls you Splurge listen it's scary Mary
this is between me and Splurge here okay
I didn't know this was a thing Scary
Mary I think Luke has a lot of nicknames
for everybody here so I'm cool with it
that means we're friends he's Lou now
yeah that's right yeah you call me Luke
that's fine blue
okay let's talk about news uh here's the
here's the first story Elon musk's
Twitter I like how they call it Elon
musk's Twitter reinstates rep Marjorie
Taylor green so this is from the past
couple of hours of course Donald Trump
has been has been reinstated don't know
if he's gonna come back project Veritas
is back James Lindsay is back who else
is back I'm seeing everybody come back
is back Andrew Tate is back anybody else
Marjory Taylor green don't know Elon
Musk is just you you think he's he's
going through a list and then just like
looking at why they were Banning back
okay we'll unban them and like who's
this and like unban them but the
graveyard of suspended accounts is just
so large that there's no way to know
who's never going to come back
well we're waiting for Sargon Carl
Benjamin to be unbanned yeah I was just
thinking of him did he get did he get on
pan I feel like I saw that today or
people were just calling for it it
Blends together yeah I think Michael
malice tweeted out that it should be
unbanned okay yeah yeah there's a bunch
of people Rick had a lot still
um he's still banned Carrie weather band
uh Dr Malone doctor
um McCullough anti-media free thought
project somebody we could keep going we
could do a whole show just by naming all
the people that have been disappeared
off of the face of the internet I know
Milo said he wouldn't come back to the
platform but so did Donald Trump
tweeting but come on my letter is this
Milo has to come back I really want him
to yeah what do you think Darren who who
needs to come back and do you think
Trump will come back oh there are a lot
of people that need to come back Trump
he desperately wants to and Elon
understands that hence the recent tweets
that he sent out expressing the uh the
temptation to which Trump is yet to give
in but
he's just got to he just finds he needs
to find the right opportunity to do so
they say they're potential legal
complications
um given his fiduciary responsibilities
to truth social so that has to be worked
out and as you know the system will use
any opportunity can get to file another
case against Trump and it looks like
there are already three or four in the
work so
um It's Complicated business with Trump
he wants to and if we subscribe to the
um uh modification of Occam's razor that
Elon propounded on Twitter namely that
the most entertaining outcome is the
most likely I think we can all expect
Trump to be on there and many more
colorful figures to come we need to we
need to pull this meme from Elon Musk he
tweeted and lead us not into into
temptation and it is the meme of the
woman showing her private parts to the
Monk and the monk is refusing to look
the monk of course is Donald Trump and
the woman's derriere is Twitter so uh
very good there's another one where it's
Lois Griffin all disheveled looking
looking over at a bottle of prescription
pills and uh uh I just got to point out
there's a woman she blocked me though
she she quoted this and then wrote this
is rape culture a billionaire promoting
rape culture on his platform and then I
was just like men not wanting to have
sex with women who want to is rape now I
guess and then she blocked me for it so
no but it's actually true the the rape
is actually him not giving in to the
dead
well if anything she's assaulting him
the the race she's you know he's just
mine he's praying right he's minding his
own business and then she comes along
and she pulls up her dress and just like
starts looking at him you know this
guy's minding his own business yeah he's
not being a simp maybe you should be
praised no but not maybe that's what
she's right
Sims sink ships okay
this is a serious deal here so uh
obviously you know you're portraying
Donald Trump doing the right thing here
right maybe maybe that's what she meant
maybe I misunderstood maybe she was
saying the woman was raping the man
was trying to imply that he was trying
to seduce Trump but it's been nearly
three days and and Trump still has the
ability to tweet but yet hasn't done it
he can't and I mean he he can't because
of uh Financial interests with truth
social so we should explain it in kind
of basic form here Trump is having the
opportunity to make a lot of money with
truth social rather than of course have
a voice on Twitter he did make a couple
statements a couple months ago saying
that he wouldn't return to Twitter even
if Elon Musk would buy it uh will he
return I think he has to if he's running
if he's going to be running a successful
presidential campaign because there's no
other way to get out in front to get
your message across but most importantly
also protect yourself against the
incoming attacks and Slanders and all
the fake news media bullcrap along with
the doj indictments there's no better
way to protect yourself than in the
court of public day uh and and that of
course means using Twitter will he use
the court of public day something I just
made up right now out a court of public
light
board of public opinion thank you thank
you do you think Elon should buy truth
social then for no more than it's worth
and then he technically wins I got the
solution literally seriously okay Donald
Trump tweets a sentence
with a link to truth social which
contains the paragraph So that way he's
still getting his idea on Twitter he's
maximizing his audience but he's
actually helping truth Social Grow I
think that's the best thing to do
because more competition in the space is
good and if he can build if he can build
another Community then we never have to
worry about monopolistic censorship from
what I read uh truth social has a six
hour exclusivity window uh and therefore
Trump must post on this is what I read
it could be wrong uh but Trump trump
must post on Truth social then six hours
later he could post the same thing on
another social media platform and
there's exceptions to the role like
fundraising uh so he can post on Twitter
According to some of the mainstream
media sources out there and they're
they're kind of larger agreement with
truth social but at the end of the day I
mean is he prioritizing money and his
platform over this platform and will
this kind of outcome be in his benefit I
don't think it will are you saying truth
social has the uh possibility of
becoming profit because I don't see that
oh definitely yeah it could be
profitable do any of us at this table
use it no well I have one and I will say
I don't use it but there's a lot of
engagement on it it is significant it's
elon's probably trying to steal back
that uh uh engagement of the users that
went over to it yeah I think Elon saw
this as a business opportunity he
probably was just like look how many
people they've kicked off the platform
that they're losing money because
they're bad at business I can come in
post some spicy memes everyone will
start screaming and spitting and yelling
they'll all come back and then we'll
we'll you know go public again in a few
years right and there's been a massive
influx into Twitter since Trump's count
was re reinstated a massive number
um so look look at this
this tweet from Donald Trump from 2011.
I feel sorry for Rosie's new partner in
love whose parents are devastated at the
thought of their daughter being with
Rosie a true loser this this history was
wiped from existence by by Vijaya God
and Dorsey and with Elon Musk coming in
we get the whole archive it's a
veritable Library of Alexandria
according
there's literal
that were being sold on Amazon wow
that's amazing
yeah I love all of Trump's old tweets
telling Robert Pattinson to break up
with Kristen Stewart I'm looking him up
now because I just love him so it's
amazing see here's the issue why don't
even even this Trump isn't on Truth
social true no it's not the true social
posts are like paragraphs about like
Maga stuff come on Donald Trump call
somebody a horse face right
we need to we need to bring back the
snarky one liners this was hilarious man
I can't believe it this stuff's 11 years
ago yeah Trump was sitting there on his
golden toilet just insulting people on
his phone and we all thought it was
funny yeah like three in the morning not
just assaulting people but like remember
when he posted his like taco bowl yeah
that's great like that's so wholesome
there's nothing so lighthearted on the
app is when that went up yeah bring back
Twitter Trump I guess man all the crazy
stuff on Trump's
Twitter thread we have to go back in
time and look at all the archives
letting me word search anything he's
tweeted right now you know there have
been glitches on on Twitter that I've
noticed mostly that you'll try and load
a tweet and then it'll say
um this tweet is unavailable or the
replies are upside down
upside down so like they usually are
below and tweet but they're above a
tweet and they're in a
non-conline the number of employees so
yeah well it's happening a lot more for
me they appear above the Tweet yeah yeah
wait yes you have to scroll up and then
it's confusing and then it's all messed
up and I love discombobulation if
Twitter implodes and is wiped off the
face of the Earth I'll take it as a win
too like you've got this platform that
is clearly biased against anyone who
opposes the establishment namely
conservatives because the Trump you know
as Trump came in but even anti-war
people are getting banned so if Elon
Musk tries to fix it it's a good thing
if he unbans people it's a good thing
this could be you guys ever hear hear
that stuff is that Pokemon he's a
terrorist oh no have you guys ever ever
he's outside have you ever heard the
story stories about how like someone on
their deathbed all of a sudden will
become like lucid and energized and
they'll sit up and start talking and be
totally normal and you'll be like oh
they're getting healthy and then they
just die you guys ever hear that
like people who are like dying and like
laying on their bed will be will just
one day get up and be like I'm feeling
better I'd like to see my family and
then the family will come in they'll all
talk and laugh and then also the person
was like bam like croak like it's the
body mustering up the last bit of energy
to make your final you know you know
finish your business and say your
goodbyes maybe this is what's happening
Elon Musk comes in we're all like yay we
feel invigorated again like it's 2015
2016 and then like the replies flip over
and and the words start getting jumbled
the tweets stop appearing and then it's
gone but it definitely doesn't feel like
2016. and then the microchip goes inside
of your head without you even noticing
it without your consent and then boom
you're connected to the new WeChat of
the United States without your consent
all right let's talk about whiny
celebrities we have uh Rolling Stone
Jack White quits Twitter calls Elon
musk's Trump reinstatement a whole move
Trent Reznor also quit like who cares
dude you guys aren't part of the
conversation you're welcome to be part
of the conversation you are part of the
conference station so you cried and left
so what you weren't tweeting anyway yeah
yeah he said that Meme that's like the
big thumbs up yeah right now you're
gonna continue with our conversation now
thank you he said this is straight up
you trying to help a fascist have a
platform so you can eventually get your
tax breaks
why are these people so
dumb yeah Elon paid the most amount of
taxes than any American citizen ever in
in history yeah so so why and who's he
accusing of being a fascist yeah who
exactly right Trump yeah Trump hasn't
tweeted it's been three days the world
hasn't ended like come on like people
take themselves way too seriously and
they're claiming that elon's forcing him
to follow Trump
that's ridiculous it's not true yeah
like that's worse than like Q Anon stuff
they're tweeting like Not only was Trump
reinstated but I found that I was
following him and I've never followed
him and I have to unfollow him and it's
like dude you you followed him come on
yeah we know you forgot who's who's this
guy Jack White The White Stripes
Seven Nation Army anything no no ring a
bell okay cool
people use a-hole as their number one
insult a-hole it's really cringy I don't
know why I don't know why that word is
part so perfect and the way they curse
it just feels like a 13 year old who has
a ghost before who's like trying to get
away with it I don't know Trent Reznor
left too and I'm just like
and yeah not very real right now no I
look you will not be but my favorite was
CBS News uh saying that they're going to
be leaving temporarily because of
security concerns and then coming back
and then still everyone's saying we
don't care we it's like it's okay
especially if you announce it you won't
have the willpower not to come back yeah
then they came back they came right back
just a few days afterwards a few hours
afterwards and it's like oh yeah we're
still looking we're monitoring the
situation like what what the thing is
none of these people can really leave
and that's why it's not the the last
kind of death croak of Twitter because
nothing on the planet has been able to
replicate the network effects that
Twitter has true I would be astonished
if it's just too valuable to too many
major stakeholders in the system just
recently you had Elon who by the way I
think he's maybe the first major Captain
of industry to mock the ADL since the
adl's Inception it's a first it's a
major thing it's incredible and he
continued it so Israel did a tweet and
Elon kind of mocked them too and but but
in a playful way saying look
um you know we need more people to tweet
we need more countries to tweet and so
if countries are tweeting
um you know it's just it's too valuable
it's it's not like there's this other
thing called what is it called like
Triceratops there there's some stupid
like left-wing version of Twitter that
they're trying to do
you can't you can't do that because of
the network of things no no no actually
actually we're learning that Mastodon is
uh quite based actually they're uh
officially telling people
if you have a problem just block them
we're not going to ban them and they're
saying I saw this woman she said that
she got suspended on Mastodon because
she was calling out white people and
they were like yeah racism you're not
allowed that was that an actual thing or
just like an algorithmic no no someone
did it and they said that her posting
about this was like she got suspended
but here's what people don't realize
Mastodon it's it's uh uh they're
different servers it's so okay so it's
the feta verse Macedon is like I guess
one note I'm not entirely sure how it
works I'm sure people in chat probably
know better but basically when you sign
up for it you pick a server hosted by
who knows and so they warn you this is
some random guy's basement you don't
know what he's doing when you sign up
for this to get off Twitter he's got all
your data your password he's got
everything and so people are signing up
and they're thinking this is going to be
better now and there's a mod as a viral
tweet where he's like yo just block
people I'm not gonna we're not Banning
like just block them even on Twitter
weren't doing that Twitter was Banning
everybody so that's turning out doing
the best but it's fair enough but I
think the point stands Twitter is
something it's Unique its function as
the global poke square is unique and it
has Network effects that
um are also unique and for that reason
um a lot of stakeholders are going to do
everything they can to prevent Elon from
going the direction he seems to be going
in he has a very difficult position he
needs to exercise
um a lot of caution he needs to approach
things with finesse and I would say so
far he's done about as well as we could
reasonably expect him to do given what
the stakes are and given what he's up
against yeah there's a couple hiccups
that he deserves to be criticized on
legitimately but you do make a good
point because where else could you see
the president of the ADL go after Elon
Musk and Elon Musk respond saying hey
stop defaming me where else where else
could you see Kanye West say shalom
right
this hive mind this this uh everybody's
reality Twitter is is amazing and the
people quitting it there's a reason
they're coming back all these people all
these actors hey I'm quitting Twitter
hey uh I'm still quitting Twitter but I
want to make one more post and another
post and this is this is again something
very similar to what we saw with uh Neil
Young with Spotify this is the same
thing we saw with all these celebrities
saying that they're going to be moving
to Canada a lot of these people are all
talk they're all bark no bite and we
have to understand these threats are
empty and they need to be called out as
ridiculous because Twitter is where it's
at right now it's fun it's entertaining
and it's where I'm at Saint Augustine
Lord make me Chase but not yet exactly
this is this is amazing when Kanye West
gets reinstated people are starting to
feel like I don't have to worry about
cancel culture anymore I don't have to
walk on eggshells so what does Kanye
tweet Shalom hilarious the ADL some some
guy he tweeted he's openly mocking us
now it's like uh-huh
so what like the problem is these people
were overly sensitive I don't think
Kanye West is as an anti-semite I think
he's probably got some wacky views I
think he's had some some silly things
but I think if he sat down with him and
talked to him you'd understand him right
it's he's not like this caricature of a
guy marching around with a hood and a
tiki torch or anything like that but
these people want to say that Libs of
tick tock for instance by simply
tweeting out I'm sorry retweeting videos
posted by people publicly she's
murdering them so there's this viral to
it I comment on it where they're like
you know uh uh Libs of tick tock has
murdered hundreds of LGBT people by
sharing these videos and it's like bro
the videos are public right literature
isn't doing anything if that's their
standard and people have to abide by
those kind of psychotic individuals
they're scared to speak out now Elon
comes in and says have fun guys and what
are we seeing spicy memes jokes trolling
and fun yeah comedy and you know what
Jack White well he doesn't like fun he
says fun is bad so he has to leave okay
bye-bye we'll play your music dude I
don't care we'll we'll have we'll have
fun and and post spicy memes
bring back the meme Wars yeah
yeah it's sad and pathetic
um but yeah the whole thing about lives
of tick tock killing people that they
have this new term that a lot of these
kind of mid-wit mediocrities with
master's degrees are talking about
um called stochastic terrorism that's
right and uh it's it's really such a
joke concept but it effectively means
that you can't criticize anyone because
of the possibility that the criticism
would be out there in The Ether and some
crazy person might attack some kind of
Affiliated group and then of course
you're responsible
um so it's the latest of of many uh
censorship predicates that and then uh
the the woman behind the libs of tick
tock what's her name Chaya is that her
name she puts stochastic terrorists in
her bio and now I'm seeing these leftist
journalists be like she's openly
bragging about doing it and I'm like are
you kidding me do you really not
understand someone being facetious
making fun of you for calling them that
or are you intentionally just trying to
lie you know what man I'm glad Elon
bought Twitter because he he took over
the space and it is nuts to see this
like Luke mentioned telling that so the
president of ADL is like I can't believe
elon's doing this when he had a meeting
with us he promised us and then Elon
says stop defaming me like that's openly
mocking them but I guess Elon Musk is
the definition of Fu money just just
outright we'll see how far it goes but
so far I think he deserves credit
because there's so many people who you
think you would have Fu money but they
never they never use it in that fashion
and I think Elon is setting an excellent
example stepping into the actual Arena
Playing for Keeps and seeing where you
know seeing where things land
um so give a major credit and uh it's
only just begun so we'll see how it
unfolds I think Elon actually tweeted at
Trent resner too or tweeted about him or
something I Don't Know Jack White posted
on Instagram some long diatribe that's
not worth reading that's not free speech
or what the poll decided or whatever
nonsense you're claiming to be this is
straight up you try to help a fascist
have a platform so you can eventually
get your tax breaks
like I don't think this guy knows
anything about tax law you know what I
mean no I mean it's the typical sort of
like maybe
105 IQ you know burned out idiot kind of
if that's high pseudo clever conspiracy
theory it's always like some dumb
Financial incentive that doesn't even
make sense if you actually know how
these things work there's a certain kind
of framework for this particular type of
accusation
um and I would peg him around 105. well
let's do this that's high for me I'm
gonna I'm gonna call out Elon Musk for
hypocrisy we have this tweet from Shuan
head
she said Elon Musk confirms he won't
reinstate Alex Jones however you feel
about Alex Jones aside am I wrong here
like not that there was much uh there
was much doubt before but Elon just
completely showed his ass Elon said my
first born child died in my arms I felt
his last heartbeat I have no mercy for
anyone who would use the deaths of
children for gain politics or fame
now that's interesting Alex Jones was
not banned from Twitter for anything
related to any kids
Alex Jones was banned from Twitter
because he insulted Oliver Darcy Elon is
insulting a reporter a bannable offense
okay ban yourself uh I'll wait
is he almost gonna ban himself he's
going to shut up okay look I can respect
all of the good things he's done the
people he's unbanned and I will accept
the win what I will not accept is I will
say it this way it is not victory for
the people that we are living beneath
the whims of a billionaire what is a
victory for the people is a clear set of
rules policies and procedures so we can
all fairly understand the rules of the
platform Elon it's your platform I
understand that what are the rules if
you come out and tell me the rule is
Free Speech I say you got it boss if you
come out and say the rule is you can't
say this that otherwise will say okay
well that's dumb but you got it boss if
you come out and tell me the rules are a
but then oh by the way I have special
rules for other people well then your
your rules are garbage and completely
meaningless now what's really happening
is you're unbanning people you like
well that's a very interesting point but
what would you say to this is that
what if in practice in terms of how
things cash out it's actually
maximizes free speech on Twitter to have
an arbitrary system rather than have a
system that follows prescribed rules
because you'd have to think what kind of
prescribed rules can get he get away
with he could say what he said before
which is that the law of the land in
terms of speech will govern speech
policy on Twitter which in the U.S would
mean First Amendment
I don't know if that's practical given
the implications I understand that so
let's say let's ask where the line is
insulting a reporter is that a bannable
offense
is that is that is that in need of
flexibility
I think they would all need flexibility
but I think it's easier to think in
terms of who would be let back on versus
kind of neutral principles that are kind
of Applied
retroactively in practice he can get
away with more if he pursues the
arbitrary of course of course in terms
of maximizing free speech on Twitter and
and he's giving himself a legal argument
here because he's outright saying that
for this personal reason he will not be
reinstating Alex Jones I will stress I
absolutely uh feel and sympathize with
Elon over this feeling of losing his son
it's a horrifying thing to have to
experience and I can I can respect and
understand that I just don't know what
it has to do with Alex Jones insulting a
reporter now if we're going to argue
there needs to be some flexibility sure
but some things are within the bounds of
the Overton window and fine insulting a
reporter you don't get banned for it now
if you're arguing that there's
harassment and what constitutes
harassment okay now we're dealing with
something more difficult well I'm saying
more that at this stage at least in
practice this his assessment and he
could very well be right on this is that
he can't get away with allowing Alex
Jones on and he is probably
um imprudent and I think he probably
stepped Over The Line in attacking Jones
the way he did but the reality is
probably he couldn't get Jones on and
that's the cost of doing all the other
stuff that he's done perhaps I
understand that but I'm not going to
apologize for for Elon of course not I
will accept the victories right and
we're seeing tremendous victories it's
it's funny we're it's fun we're laughing
there's jokes there's memes and all Elon
had to do was not address the issue
outright it's probably the safest thing
for him to do is like he's not addressed
Carl Benjamin we all want him on band
he's not addressed Milo but he did
specifically address Alex then said he's
not going to unban him because he did a
thing six years prior to his Twitter ban
that offends Elon Annette right there I
get it maybe he's gonna have a legal
argument in the future that I that
clearly shows I will ban whoever I want
for whatever reason there's no rules
whatsoever and by doing so so if he does
ban you you can't sue him for breach of
contract because he he's clearly
operating on a win I'm happy he's at
least telling us where his flawed
decision is coming from because it's an
illogical decision that shows you that
there's no Pathway to Redemption and
he's using emotional trauma in order to
justify this larger Banning for
something that Alex Jones has already
apologized for something that Alex Jones
is being fined 1.5 billion dollars for
something that of course cost Alex Jones
almost everything but but at the end of
the day here if we're going to be
punishing people for using children for
their own political gain or fame uh my
original response to this was hey Elon
Musk have you heard of uh Barack Obama
the guy who dropped uh a bomb every 20
minutes for for eight years the guy who
judicially extra extrajudiciously
assassinated a 16 year old American
citizen if we're going to be punishing
people for hurting children we might as
well ban the president of the United
States let's not even get into big
Pharma we don't even have to go into
Bitcoin come on there a minute Joe Biden
out there groping and sniffing kids
right now you gonna ban them that's a
lot different than dropping a bomb on
small children I get it I'm saying
Obama's not the president anymore so we
have that argument so ban him obviously
and Joe Biden who's currently the
president is on camera groping and
sniffing children so how about we have a
standard oh that's the problem there's
no standard is there any off-platform
Behavior warrants a ban nope well this
is what Jack Conte of uh what's a
patreon uh argued specifically he he
created this new term off platform
Behavior off-platform off off yeah yeah
off platform Behavior which is
absolutely ridiculous because again
you're going to arbitrarily say you did
this 10 years ago or 20 years ago I
don't like that culture culture but but
again
my personal preference which I hope
ultimately he'll be able to achieve is
the first amendment standard but he's a
lot more practical than I think people
realize and the First Amendment standard
it sounds something like something very
easily publicly defensible when you put
it that way but then you say okay first
amendment standard means all legal
speech that means that probably the most
banned people on the internet
like Andrew Anglin has to go on Twitter
I'm for that because I'm for the First
Amendment standard but as a matter of
practical reality that's a hell of a lot
of incoming that Elon would have right
up front and so what kind of principles
can you pick that would cash out better
at least in this initiative
don't say you believe in free stuff if
the assumption is that uh perhaps he's
playing a game of 40 chest three yes and
then then he should not have addressed
the issue at all because if your
argument is he has to to play the game
that means he's virtue signaling right
don't care for virtue signaling I don't
care for being lied to and I don't care
for petty uh I I don't care I shouldn't
say it that way but I don't care for
personalized arguments as to why certain
people are below the standards I agree I
I think he shouldn't have gone there and
said oh you know use the kid thing
um that was unfortunate and cross the
line line and uh and he clearly doesn't
know anything about it sorry to
interrupt right no I agree no I I'm
totally with you there I want the First
Amendment standard I'm just trying to
put myself in Elon shoes and I'm
thinking as much as we want a kind of
neutral principled standard such that we
can say well if you do this what about
this which is you know how fairness
operates
um but in terms of the result the kind
of consequentialist uh view of it is
that he can actually probably maximize
Free Speech more if he does virtue
signal a little bit at least in these
early stages there was there was
something infuriating uh about Jack
Dorsey and vajayagade lying to your face
when you were like hey why was this
person banned and why wasn't this person
when you'd say something like hey look
here's an antifa account advocating for
instructing violence and they go oh well
it's a mistake and then they still won't
take it down
when they tell you we're working on it
there will be a path of redemption I
hear you I hear what you're saying we're
going to try and fix it it's frustrating
because you know they're lying to you
it's even worse when it's a billionaire
who just says too bad
like it's one thing to be like I can I
can I can I can hold on to that one
percent hope that Jack Dorsey means it
when he says we're gonna find a way to
get people back on the platform we got
to figure out how to do it it's another
thing when Elon Musk is like I bought it
it's mine too bad there's no rules I can
do whatever I want and if we can't trust
them on this what makes you think we
can't trust them on on other issues as
well this brings a lot of doubt and
speculation because he's acting on
emotion rather than morals and virtues
rather than saying hey I believe in free
speech that means speech for people I
despise he says no I don't like him but
but Elon have you heard of uh a thing
called Epstein's Island that there's a
former president there that used to
attended Bill Clinton he's also on your
platform right now if you care about
children and children you would be going
after them but he's not and and having
this kind of made-up scenario where you
say he's okay but he's not good based
off your own emotional trauma is not
something that gives me a lot of Hope in
this platform moving forward we all
agree that the first amendment should be
the ultimate standard Free Speech no I
disagree you did I think I think even
for Twitter I disagree and on one issue
docson okay there's probably enough uh
the First Amendment doesn't cover
criminal acts there's there's challenges
to whether or not something can be
deemed uh criminal of its speech so so
first amendment minus doxing not
necessarily so listen
uh the first some people are free speech
absolutists they believe that words can
never be criminal no matter what you
said that means literally they think
incitement to violence and instruction
on how to do horrible things and there's
an interesting point there
if we argue that there is Criminal
speech in any capacity we're arguing
Congress can pass a statutory law
criminalizing speech that makes no sense
right
so the Supreme Court upheld upholds
basically that if you incite violence
that is not protected by the First
Amendment now my question is I
understand that I understand the
arguments but how does that make sense
Congress isn't making the law the
Supreme Court just said as we interpret
what the first amendment is supposed to
mean we've carved out an exception not
the founding fathers in Covenant
exception so there's an interesting
argument there because if we do agree
that incitement of violence is is
Criminal and not free speech what
happens if Congress or the Supreme Court
what happens to the Supreme Court for
instance rules that actually hate speech
is incitement because of stochastic
terrorism are we going to continue to
allow the courts to decide if there are
more larger and larger limits to speech
so I don't know that
um also saying the First Amendment
standard is not good enough because it's
subject to Future kind of modifications
from the Supreme Court's sort of
interpretive because the freeze because
the First Amendment
could be argued to mean you can incite
to violence and so there's limits Beyond
so my point is this
in the future the Supreme Court May rule
that doxing someone is not free
expression it's a it's it's actually a a
a attack against or something it's a
violation of someone's privacy and thus
criminal it would be interesting if
Congress ruled that posting someone's
private information this this may be a
court that has a case that has to be
adjudicated actually if Congress tries
passing a law saying posting someone's
private home details or or private
information phone number contact Etc uh
without their permission constitutes a
crime the Supreme Court is going to
determine whether or not that violates
Free Speech because posting someone's
address doesn't really express your
political opinion or views and that's an
argument some people make about what
free speech is anyway I don't want to
over make it overly complicated the
first amendment is an easy thing to say
but we really do need bullet point
breakdown of what is okay and what isn't
uh Gaba for instance I believe bans
doxing okay and that's free speech you
could walk around with a big old sign
with someone's address on it but on gab
you can't do that I agree I don't think
you should be allowed to post someone's
private details I don't think there
should be permanent bans for these
things however because you know I argue
this to Jack Dorsey there are people who
commit murder and they get out in 25
years sure there's a guy who who you
know posted a nasty Meme and you've
permanently removed his ability to speak
in the public there's no Redemption
according to the
um Theology of cancellation I just want
to point out the Clinton Global
initiatives on Twitter
you know yeah there's a lot of war
criminals and monsters there's you know
terrorist organizations that are on
there openly using the platform without
any kind of problems when Twitter a
couple years ago was looking at of
course right-wing talking points that
they needed to censor and take down so
uh it's crazy because this this is a
very important issue and and we can't
underplay it because yes I mean we got
to celebrate our victories Elon did
incredible things on Banning a lot of
important people that were uh punished
for their political speech but if you're
going to continue the punishment based
on your own kind of made up uh standards
that that's something that doesn't give
me hope that's something that I think a
lot of people should be skeptical of and
I think that's something that a lot of
people should be criticizing him on
because obviously it doesn't stand with
any kind of virtue let's pull up this uh
this tweet here now I'm not I'm not sure
if this is confirmed I don't know but
you guys have probably seen it all over
the place this is from stux on Mastodon
he says what's it with people reporting
every single person they don't like
please stop with that this is not
Twitter please use features like mute or
block if you don't like people but stop
reporting otherwise I'll start Banning
people who keep reporting for nothing
I'm trying to keep things running with
so many new people and it's such a waste
of time to hear whatever you don't like
otherwise go waste elon's time not mine
Elon Musk tweeted please Hall monitors
go on someone else's platform it was
Nate silver who said that he thinks
Mastodon is a Honeypot for the hall
monitor types all of these people on
Twitter who report everything and won't
shut up are leaving and going to
Mastodon and all Spider-Man meme
pointing at each other and uh we're all
having a good time it's like there's a
party going on and they left so you know
I'll take it how many employees have
been slashed so far at Twitter are they
oh man
where like they don't have as many
moderators
than no moderators none I'm pretty sure
their moderation team's gone they've got
to have some people no I I think because
they've like they've now like
streamlined the process for reporting
child exploitation materials which I
have been waiting for them to do for so
long because they made it unnecessarily
difficult you had to go through on the
desktop version uh and go through a
longer process to do that so they they
streamline that process they have to
have a good moderation team to keep up
with that and there's been like I've
seen reports that there are doing a
Crackdown on child exploitation yeah
he's the number one priority he said but
you can't do that without moderators and
that's true good point I mean before the
moderators were just like acting like
demagogues
about you know
not if you were having a conversation
with someone and you weren't being
academic enough in your language then
you would get banned pretty much right
well there it is there's also you're
just at the mercy of like any random
school that comes across this let me let
me say real quick since the uh beginning
of the election month or like October
and then we're getting into November
all of my videos pertaining to election
issues have been demonetized for fake
reasons
and it's it costs a lot of money it
really does like getting getting you
know when you when when you know I cut
down the amount of videos I do
I went from uh what was I doing like six
to three
having one it's it's it's bad it's a lot
of money yeah and what happens is I'll
get the yellow dollar sign and then I'll
I'll request review which takes a day
you get all the views in your day then
you get no money
if it is confirmed like the next day
it'll say confirmed demonetized by
manual review and it will say harmful or
dangerous activity and it's me reading a
poll and being like the polls are in and
they say this that and then I gotta call
Google and then they're like whoops that
was an accident let's fix it for you and
I'm like who are you employing who's
lying on all of them they're clearly
leftists well it happens to every one of
my videos but I have no one to call so
like you saw my stats you saw my income
it's absolutely insane what's happening
on my YouTube channel But to answer your
question there's also a lot of
third-party companies uh usually a lot
of international workers that get hired
to do a lot of this moderation some of
the moderation is done in-house but a
lot of it is done through of course
other private companies in Africa in
Asia where of course the labor there is
a lot cheaper and we and and this has
been documented many times even with
project Veritas project Veritas even
released an expose talking about how
Twitter employees were paid to view at
everything including private messages
people's posts how Twitter Engineers
were there to of course Implement Shadow
Banning this is Project Veritas talking
to Twitter Engineers that were bragging
about having Trump's private DM messages
and were threatening to release them so
again when we look at that content
moderation when we look at the
destruction of speech we have so much
power by so many few individuals that
absolutely use it and abuse it for the
worst Sinister political purposes and if
you dare to speak outside of the
established narratives you're going to
get punished you're going to get screwed
over and that's exactly what's happening
to to my YouTube channel they're in such
an extensive way there's another
dimension of demonetization that is very
relevant to elon's predicament with
Twitter and that is the latest scam of
brand safety which is basically like a
mafia Shakedown because in some cases
they have third world Imports in some
cases they just have
um just you know uh regular people but
what they do is they basically quickly
tell tell these advertising agencies
they say you know you're you're at your
advertisement with this site is really
inappropriate for your brand I think you
should reconsider and if you don't it
would be a shame if something happened
to you and they have a whole
infrastructure in place to make good on
their threat and so it really is like
it's a typical mob Shakedown the basic
framework hasn't changed but they sell
it as brand safety meaning your brand is
in danger if you don't do exactly what
we say and stop advertising with this
website that we don't like and we object
to no matter how much money it's making
you and no matter how much the audience
actually likes the content on that
website and it happens on a large scale
that's exactly the type of Shakedown
that's happening on Twitter now and I
bet you that our good friend Jonathan
Greenblatt of the ADL is hard at work
making sure that these potential
advertisers and current advertisers are
sufficiently intimidated but it happens
on a smaller scale too to a wide range
of sites that distribute content that
the regime finds objectionable and
including yours including mine in a very
big way I have one stalker woman who's
absolutely obsessed with me every time
we get some kind of new uh ad
Arrangement she's she has a a tweet
Thread about it it's it's really
pathetic they actually a blue check
I don't know about that I don't know
what the the her cast is and I don't
want I don't want to give her attention
so like by saying her name but we can
talk about her in the I don't like
giving but but this woman and I think
it's the same person went after a a
Weather Network like what yeah no no
joke no joke there's a a there's a cable
channel that does nothing but weather
and this leftist woman started like
tweeting about it and she's well like a
lot of these amount of followers her
friends in media write up her stories
and then she's actually getting
advertisers to pull off a weather
reporting station and it's just like wow
the only thing on the screen is it says
like weather it's like raining in Texas
like that's the sad thing the sad thing
is how easily so many of these people
cave because usually they're liaison
their point of contact at these
companies is like some 20-something
woman who is ideologically aligned and
even if not all these unsophisticated
people need to hear is the phrase
conspiracy theory or you know Trump or
something like that and automatically is
like okay bad danger you know that's all
I need to hear or even worse
or even worse than older woman without a
family that is there to complain as well
[Laughter]
thing that happened with the YouTube
adpocalypse is that what you're saying
that was really different well the
models they're saying oh the the brands
who are advertising mid-rolls on YouTube
Can't rely on whether the YouTube
channels they're advertised next to
reflect their brand values and I always
thought that was ridiculous on its face
because YouTube channels including this
one are Brands they're companies in and
of themselves and they deserve to you
know have advertisers that align with
their values right but let's not forget
at the end of the day advertisers have a
choice to not advertise return creators
you could go as an Advertiser and you
could go into the Google settings and
say I don't like Alex Jones I don't like
you can choose that you could choose who
you advertise with than not and as a
content creator I could say hey I don't
want any advertisements for the US
military I don't want McDonald's
advertisements I don't want these kind
of politicians and these kind of ads
associated with my brand and I could do
that just like master
yes you can I I used to be able to do
that and I used to say I don't want any
McDonald's ads I don't want any um you
still do that
um
on YouTube uh on Google on Google on
your website you mean uh no no no on
Google there was a setting I remember
doing this for your YouTube channel I
remember doing this a few years ago
saying I don't want to advertise with I
don't want these advertisers on my
YouTube I don't know how to do that I I
could show you okay that's definitely
fair right but but but it's fair exactly
but but we don't hear about this a lot
of the people don't know that
advertisers have a choice and and if
they find someone despicable or they
don't want anyone tied in with their
associate they don't have to have it
they already have the infrastructure
that's not why they're pulling ads
they're pulling ads because the far left
marches around with bricks and
conservatives sitting there lazy boys
complaining that's it
so until law enforcement the the
solution and that's why they wanted to
fund the police partly why law
enforcement needs to stop these people
and and we need to develop some kind of
system and stuff I notice that the
easiest example is
storefronts in Berkeley will put up all
the leftist signs in their window
because they know if someone throws a
brick through their window the cops
can't do anything about it like your car
can get stolen good luck the cop's gonna
be like well
we'll write down the the we'll write
down the license plate and then if we
see it we'll let you know but if you've
got something like a bike your bike's
gone if you've got something like a
moped your moped is gone it gets stolen
the cops job and say what do you want to
do about it so if you piss off the far
left who are psychotic violent
individuals and they start harassing
your neighbor or the cops are going to
be like what do you want us to do about
it so what do they do they say look Dave
Rubin is not going to March this is the
example I love given Dave Rubin is never
going to march to Twitter HQ to complain
about the censorship he's never going to
march with a bunch of classical liberals
carrying torches to YouTube HQ to say no
more censorship he's going to go and
he's going to complain about it and
that's all he's going to do antifa will
literally throw up with crowbars and
beat the crap out of people that
terrifies them so they say I know who to
avoid and who to cater to so these big
Brands when they hear that far leftists
are attacking them they immediately say
guys Red Alert do whatever they say and
they'll go away that's that's that's
that's it yeah it's going to be
interesting to see how Elon Musk kind of
navigates this very uh changing media
advertising landscape because right now
just a couple of minutes ago he's
promising Twitter being a good video
platform that's going to offer quote
according to Elon Musk higher
compensation for creators than YouTube
so this is something that Elon Musk just
tweeted a couple of moments ago
responding to Mr Beast how is he going
to be doing that specifically with so
many ad advertisers boycotting him will
there be other advertisers and also by
and large advertisers are pulling back
naturally not because of cancer culture
but because of the way that the economy
is just being absolutely screwed over
right now just how poorly it's doing
right now compared to everything else I
think Sargon got unbanned I think Rakata
and Sargon got on band during the Carl
Benjamin is back wow dude it's been so
long
wow that's amazing this is what people
in the chat are saying yeah we got a
Super Chat someone just said it I had to
announce it uh Carl's awesome he's a
good friend he helped me actually uh get
all the stuff rolling when uh when I
started doing YouTube full-time he hit
me up and asked me if I would do a guest
spot on his channel he had like 300 000
subscribers I had like 40 and I was like
yeah for sure man I made a video ended
up getting hundreds of thousands of hits
all of a sudden I gained a whole bunch
of subscribers and it helped get the
ball rolling so very grateful to Carl
Benjamin he's a good dude he hosts Lotus
Eaters podcasts glad to see that he's
he's been restored finally after all
these years yeah to Twitter oh man this
will be fun apparently rakit alone was
like literally during the show so yeah I
know just right now people are saying uh
that uh that that they're back great
this is amazing yeah so uh look Elon man
wins a win I'll take it I'm not I'm I'm
not going to ignore the problems I see
with the Alex Jones stuff but I will
stress it again hey man like this is a
huge Victory so take what you can get I
suppose and Dot and we'll roll with it I
will say this now too
there's a tough question about
do we give Elon the eight dollars
I'm leaning towards yes because I said
if he freed the political prisoners I
would sign up because I want the
features it's all good stuff and I want
to see Twitter succeed they they deleted
my ad campaign I tried advertising the
super Maga shirt it's where Trump's
going Super Saiyan and they said it was
political you can't do it I said okay so
I tried doing the rooster shirt and the
ad ran for like four hours and then they
took it down saying it was inappropriate
Elon I'm trying to give you money man
like what's going on here weiner jokes
it's a rooster it says stand your ground
I thought it was cool I'm like okay I'll
try this but anyway
I think uh The Alex Jones things is
unfortunate and I think elon's wrong and
I and for everything we described but
I'm going to take this win and we got to
see Twitter make it so I I think you
know it's time to sign up we already got
Tim cast news signed up we'll we'll get
our other accounts we'll get pop culture
pop culture crisis verified we'll get
all our business accounts verified I
think unbanning Sargon for me is kind of
like oh wow like he's a personal friend
you know so that's a lot yeah and we
also we also now know exactly why Alex
Jones is coming back like now at least
elon's clarified his reasons for not
having him on the platform whether
they're not so sure he doesn't have
ulterior motives and he's just saying
that before this motive that's cool you
mean yeah I don't know like what would
be the game there
I have no idea he gives up the Alex
Jones Pawn but what other Pawn does he
get or like what more powerful than Elon
Musk that can threaten him financially
well he he has a very interesting
conflict with Bill Gates which I think
is fascinating to see unfold
um and and you know Tim you bring up a
good question it does kind of bring down
a different kind of Paradigm here do you
do you support him for doing all this
good when he did this one thing that's
bad it's it's a tough call for a lot of
people but I'm kind of leaning on like
hey he freed a lot of political
prisoners he's giving them a lot of
voices and for me I think that's worth
eight bucks it's a girlfriend probably
Elon Musk has some girlfriend on the
side who's like telling him you can't
you can't unband Alex Jones that must be
it that's more likely than anything
[Music]
um
I don't think so women have powerful
persuasion I'm not I'm trying to get the
tweets to load on us our verbatas
but uh I don't see any tweets on
sargon's account maybe they got I think
people are saying in the comment section
that he's still sleeping
you know what I mean like his old tweets
aren't back either but I can see glitch
though and it's yeah because it's like
whenever they unban you it slowly comes
right Kata only has a couple thousand
followers but they're slowly getting
back a lot of people are saying that
when Trump was back people weren't
allowed to follow him but but that
usually was happened when people were
reinstated it took a while until they're
all their followers and everything kind
of came back to normal I wonder if he's
gonna unban people who invade did
suspension and made new counts like over
and over again it's been like five years
I think since Sargon got banned right
yeah it's been it's like one of the
first things yeah so he never made
another account don't think so um
well that's a great Zone there yeah
we'll just leave it at that Mark they
were impersonating him let's uh let's
jump to this next uh tweet because my
friends we're gonna have fun
Lauren Chen tweeted Twitter before Elon
versus Twitter after Elon the before
picture it's all women the after picture
it's all men yeah but there's like a
woman right there and it's like a woman
right there that might be a woman right
there I'm not sure but it looks like two
over here I think there's like six guys
there's like one two three lots of soy
boys four five six oh yeah is that six
one two three four five six soy is
palpable shot that guy right there you
can smell it and taste the soy just
imagine the stench okay so here's the
thing here's the thing I tweeted Elon
didn't fire women he asked who wanted to
work hard LMFAO
because he put out this email where he
was like everybody we're all going to be
working really really hard
if you don't want to stay then take a
three-month Severance and get out yeah
and then uh these are the guys who
stayed late with Elon however there was
a fact check oh the fact check I guess
has been removed the bird watch thing
got taken down and it said that it's not
a before and after it's just the comms
team versus the engineering team which
also made me laugh because once again it
shows a very clear difference between
males and females on the issue the women
are subject oriented the males are are
object oriented but uh the truth is it
is this image of the of all these women
is from a tweet where a woman at Twitter
says I'm leaving on November 4th I'm
quitting so it quite literally is a
woman being like it's been fun I quit
here's a picture of my team and then the
picture of all the guys being like we're
staying until 2 A.M to do hard work yeah
my response to this tweet was uh the
women on the left better learn to code
automatically uh and and then you you do
see a big clear kind of difference and
obviously there are different teams and
to answer your question Mary
specifically the misinformation team is
gone but the moderation team is still
there so there are a lot of people who
have different kind of political belief
systems that are aligned usually with
their genders we we saw and and they're
kind of um relationships we saw during
these latest midterms that one of the
biggest voting blocs that voted for the
Democrats were women that didn't have a
partner and those were people that came
out and voted more than they previously
have before so so clearly there is a big
kind of political shift and difference
between these two pictures as well and I
think it's pretty clear to to see the
difference
these chicks to their own devices
clearly
leads to disaster every time
oh man I bet they feel aggrieved right
now aggrieved I did a segment on this I
was talking about how um
56 of women prefer to be in the
workforce according to Gallup
56 that's actually not that many yeah
exactly there were like an all-time high
56 I'm like you're telling me that half
of women don't want to be at work plus
the women the women who report that they
want to be in the workforce but actually
don't
that's probably a huge percentage as
well
socially driven subject oriented Etc
there's going to be a lot of women who
are like I is it bogus young again
the cat is at the studio door yelling
because should I let him in no
absolutely not why because woke me up at
seven o'clock in the morning I'm pissed
at him and he is it's terrorist cat
hungry that's what I'm talking about
he's a cat
what is taxoplasmosis is real and I just
don't get along with that cat I have
toxic we help because we have super nice
no he's not he loves it absolutely not
we all love him absolutely yeah anyway
about these women yeah oh yeah I was
just wondering also like cat ladies
thank you heptoplasmosis a real thing I
want to know how many mothers uh report
wanting to stay in the workforce it's
probably an even lower number once
they've started working I don't know
it's funny because uh we did a segment
on this and The Young Turks did a
segment mocking me saying like you know
I said I I said of of the women that
probably don't want our hamburgers after
what I said I said there are probably
some women somewhere who say they want
to work but don't and I was like very
vague with it and I was like they're
gonna be unhappy if they don't have
families and then The Young Turks to
this huge segment where they were like
Tim pool thinks women want to be
stay-at-home wives or whatever and I'm
like yo Gallup says they do like as half
of women do but the reason I bring that
up is because
before kova the amount of men that were
staying at home stay-at-home dads one to
five percent
that's ridiculously low relative to
women so guys want to be out in the
workforce women prefer to be at home
working at home because it's this is the
craziest thing to me this idea that like
taking care of a house and kids doesn't
work
all of a sudden now it's like do you
want to be at work or stay at home it's
like well they're both work you know
because it's only work if it benefits
some third-party conglomerate basically
right yeah just a quick observation
about this this picture now that I'm
looking at it it really
it represents a different dimension
According to which musk is challenging
the system because there's the Free
Speech Dimension we're talking about but
also like when you really think about
how major corporations are structured
it's actually borderline illegal to have
a corporation that's set up to maximize
efficiency and output
in California it's borderline illegal
even at a national level in California
now it's illegal but it goes to show in
one hand you can look at the left side
of the picture and say probably useless
it's maybe a you know the project it's
the the project manager uh Massacre you
could call it but but on the other hand
there's so many useless people that
companies are somewhat obliged to hire
in order to Shield themselves from a
whole range of legal liabilities that
have been sort of built into the Nexus
between the
corporate economic structure and the
legal structure and so there's this
weird sort of
Phantom utility to having all of this
dead weight in a company simply as legal
protection and political protection from
precisely these third-party NGO ADL type
rackets that exist to shake down your
company yeah it's like an artificially
inflated HR department it's exactly what
it is and a lot of people a lot of these
people don't work we saw it from The
Tick Tock videos they're like we're
going for our morning mimosas and then
we're going to support the the
African-American in my own business yeah
vegan restaurant downstairs that caters
for us all the Caterers are supposed to
be there for us but the office is empty
wonder why you want to pull this up yeah
yeah so this is uh
I don't want to play it too loud a tale
of two different realities check out
this video
two guys on the right I don't know I
don't know
it's an oil rig they're just gonna add
pipe or take pipe away as it goes down
oh that's what they're doing that's what
the guys do it looks like they're really
good look at that they're covered in in
filth of some sort yeah
and on the left it's a woman who's
talking about going to her little booth
and getting smoothies and eating her
chicory boards and having her wines and
living a yucky lifestyle and having her
little meditation food the world on the
left is only possible because of the
world
yay we have to play foosball
oh oh now I should get her safe space
look at that this is my farting room I
go in there and I
yoga mats uh yeah
yeah yo it's so
disgusting absolutely seeing what these
companies are and I've seen them
firsthand I've been to Google HQ but
I've been I've been there San Francisco
and New York offices they're LA offices
it is absolutely insane it is it is
daycare I can't even begin to describe
it having having come from a life where
I've had look at that wine dispenser
like a red wine dispenser for for her
plastic couple these guys oh cool they
got the corn working the oil rig on the
roof wow on the roof and she'll get
better how what can we do to get all
these people fired from their jobs
I think Elon just get him pregnant get
them pregnant oh no no they're just
gonna go get abortions live at company
paid for it by Eli musk Elon Musk is
allowing employees to get paid abortions
and it's paying for their travel so Elon
Musk still is a part of this yeah he's
funding it yes Elon Musk is funding his
employees to go out of state to get
abortions that's amazing so again I mean
it's a quick check on that yeah right
now fact Checker Tesla right yeah Tesla
specifically but this is probably going
to be the same women's ability probably
also going to be the same policy in
California because in California it's
probably mandated by law women's ability
to create and sustain life definitely
makes them weaker in the workforce and
uh you either have policies like that or
you're going to hire women less you
wonder also how much what function these
project managers types are really
serving there's the sort of Legal Shield
then there's also the morale question
you know maybe they're just kind of
giving those guys on the right side of
the picture something something to look
at after a hard four hour coding session
oh no hold on hold on that that was
inappropriate Darren for our coding
session these people don't code
and four hours is way too much time for
them these are these are like they might
break a nail no no I'm talking about the
right side of the picture with all of
the engineer guys maybe the project
managers are there for morale they're
like depends that's so true yeah you
know that that because they don't have
lives to come home to and those guys on
the right they wouldn't be able to do
all that hard piping work if it wasn't
further you see the Twitter employee the
project managers go there for the
smoothies but the project managers are
the smoothies for the Coatings
that's so awesome the way the way I was
describing it earlier is that um the
most important role in my opinion is the
stay-at-home mom or stay-at-home Dad if
Dad wants if Dad's doing it but the
person who's actually protecting and
taking care of the family because if a
guy were to go out and fight a bear with
his with his own hands and and take it
down for the question is for what
purpose he's an opportunity he's got if
he has no family he has no one to
protect so what's the point of fighting
the bear if he's able to just take care
of himself he can eat Badger rabbit and
whatever else he wouldn't be able to
actually eat the bear so the great
conquests of the man who's going out and
working hard is only for the family and
if there's no one there to actually help
protect his family then what's the point
yeah raising the family is the most
important job you could have in our
society or who else is going to be
raising them but they make it
disrespectful yeah so like when I say
something like half of women would
prefer to be at home the left gets
offended by it how dare you we would be
better served working fifty thousand
dollar a year jobs for some
multi-millionaire in his Factory okay
okay I guess I don't think so I think
you'd be better served raising kids and
having a family and teaching human
beings to exist that's not what the
state and Central controllers want they
want a bigger tax base they want a
bigger base of sheep they want people
that don't get to raise their children
so the indoctrination Center get to
raise them so the big social Tech media
platforms get to raise them so the
televisions the boob tubes gets to raise
them and when of course you have
children raised by the state you have
better sheep and that's of course what
they're also looking for in my opinion
better that you don't have children at
all though you're just the last of your
line of progeny I disagree especially
with the upcoming population collapse
that's going to be coming and destroying
and wreaking havoc on civilization
I'm just saying I think the corporation
should have should be having children no
I do too I'm saying the corporations
would rather you not have children at
all than indoctrinate your children oh
well yeah that's trouble for them I
think I'm going to take a class on how
to build an electric motor
just because if there is a population
collapse you know I'll I'll I'll I'll
stop and I'll rephrase it population
collapse is a terrifying thing if if you
think about it
the only reason I have a cell phone
right now that can pull up videos and do
all this crazy stuff is because there's
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of people who know how to do
each and every one of these little
things to make it right there's a person
who Minds the raw materials the rare
Earths the metals who uh there's a
company that makes the glass yeah so
it's not you know like apple makes it or
Android makes it then there's a company
that makes the chips there's a company
that makes the cameras it all comes
together into this device
if the glass company ceases to exist
touch screens are gone like what do you
get plastic screen maybe with buttons If
the rare Earths are gone well now we got
to Source them from somewhere else we
can't get that if we lose access to
these specialty positions I'll tell you
if there's a population collapse we will
lose more than people realize because it
is only because of the massive
population that we're able to have such
highly refined and Powerful tools
Specialties as there's more more and
more people there's finer and finer
Specialties you go back 500 years
actually you go back thousands of years
it was possible to as one as a single
person to know everything humans knew
just being one person like because there
was so little knowledge now there's so
much knowledge there's no way one person
could actually manufacture a cell phone
by themselves let alone a toaster that
famous Ted Talk where a guy says I tried
to make a toaster from scratch this is
what it'll be like if population
collapse happens it'll be a hundred
years from now you'll have a kid and
you'll be telling a story about how we
used to have small devices they were
like cards and you'd touch it and you
could make images appear you could
control people on the screen on the
screen you can move them around you knew
where it was raining around the world
you could talk to anyone around the
planet those kids are going to be like
that's magic yeah you're gonna be an old
person like I swear we had this thing
look and there will be like relics of it
and the kids are like how do you even
use it how does it even turn on I'm like
well the Network's gone the technology
is gone we lost it all forget about this
and to them they'll hear the story and
then they'll tell their kids magic and
then in 50 years 60 years the kids are
going to be alike they used to believe
in magic so dumb yeah I know forget
about the luxuries the medical
implications are also going to be very
vast because there's not going to be
enough young people to take care of the
old people there's going to be so many
horrible effects especially when it
comes to the larger economic system
which is going to collapse especially
with the lack of people since of course
economies grow with people less people
less growth bigger collapse Japan is a
good yes for all of this because first
of all Japan is one of the lowest if not
the lowest fertility rates all the
places with the lowest fertility rates
seem to be the most technologically
advanced but then other than you know
the west and European countries that
seem to have attempted to solve this
problem by importing massive amount of
people from the developing World Japan
has decided it to develops robots to
replace them which may in the end turn
out to have been a better choice we you
just don't know
um so I don't think so well China is
also doing something very similar they
have very weird robots that we can't
talk about on the show that I brought up
before that everyone here knows about
but but China also is is facing a huge
but then there are these these Boston
Dynamics robots they're terrifying and
I've been on good authority that
actually there's an ulterior motive
there is that actually the Boston
Dynamics robots are secretly programmed
for a future in which it is a state law
that everybody has to watch Alex
Friedman videos
the Boston Dynamic robots will come
you have to watch at least three per
month
the Boston Dynamic robot shows up at
your house and then a screen comes out
and Alexa have you seen I mean
you're being chased the dogs are running
after you with screens on their back and
you're like
and they pin you down and it just plays
I don't want to listen
meanwhile Alex is just talking to you
quietly well I don't what it's like you
guys don't like Lex Friedman's show or
what I think he's fine I think it's
fascinating I nothing for or against but
I think it's
safe to say it's fair to say that this
is the most algorithmically driven
phenomenon on the entire internet I hear
so many stories of saying I went to bed
watching this on YouTube and I woke up
and Lex Friedman was on it's like all
paths lead to Friedman and it's a very
interesting thing you wonder sometimes
how these uh phenomena occur
um maybe he's just such a great
charismatic interviewer that it's just
manifestly obvious why he would you know
be elevated to such a station with so
many uh interesting guests maybe there
are other factors but I I definitely
think
um it's
you know I really think the Boston
Dynamic robots they're they're made to
enforce it maybe there's going to be a
scotus decision just like the Obamacare
they can force you to buy health
insurance they can force you to watch
the Friedman videos
um there are all sorts of possibilities
in the future I always get recommended
to him all the time and I'm like no I
just don't want to like all the time
non-stop did they fall asleep watching
Lex Friedman or do they end up on Lex
Freedom that's also a good question to
to think they well there you go no no
disrespect Lex it's all good he's just
spreading love but it's nothing against
him but it is weird it is the most
algorithmically driven thing on the
entire internet remember that story
about that uh that chick who lived in
the van she put up two YouTube videos
and then got millions of subscribers
it was uh it exposes that there is
absolutely an algorithm driving
everything and controlling what you what
you see and uh my conspiracy theory is
that the van life trend on YouTube was
to try and convince Millennials to not
buy stuff and to live in a pod right and
live in the body the bugs eat the bugs
and and not own anything because people
can't own homes now it's you know their
parents are telling them hey you should
say about money and own a home that's
not possible for the average person
nowadays with the salaries that they're
having with how much uh you know the
price of real estate has increased
that's impossible but you could have a
van by the river right or you could have
some uh you know cryptocurrencies you
could have some tether right yes
do we have time together watch some
watch some Lex buy some tethers you know
get into little geometric Unity Theory
there you go do we have time to talk
about uh your article because you wrote
a very interesting article just the
short and like you know like Tim said
there's been a lot of talk about tether
for a long time but this piece that's up
on my news site revolver.news it's
generating a lot of Buzz and crypto
world and otherwise and I'll just lay
out the basic data points and people can
kind of decide for themselves uh it's a
very weird story it's the third largest
cryptocurrency in existence it's a
stable coin meaning that its value is
not it's not mined in the way that
Bitcoin is or ethereum that's its value
allegedly comes from US dollar reserves
backing the tether
it's never been fully or properly
audited in its entire existence which is
weird given that its whole value is
based on the fact that it allegedly has
these reserves and then if you look at
the cast of characters behind tether one
of them is a washed up child Disney
actor called Brock Pierce who was
involved in all sorts of things a weird
sort of underage sex scandal that he got
embroiled in he was apprehended by
Interpol in Spain there is allegedly
child pornography and all this stuff
involved in the apprehension he was not
arrested weirdly and then he turns up as
the founder of this major cryptocurrency
which is a stable coin which has never
been audited which defies the U.S
treasury treasury in in various respects
and which just happens to be the
official cryptocurrency of several U.S
backed Rebel groups
geopolitically including the rohingya
rebel groups in Myanmar and so the
thesis
a deuced in this piece suggests that
there could be an historical antecedent
to the function that tether May uh
fulfill and that is the BCCI bank which
is this Bank set up by the CCA or the
CIA uh to facilitate all kinds of money
laundering operations and so forth
but the cast of characters is really
remarkable here of course there's a
Jeffrey Epstein connection and so I
encourage everyone to go and look at it
and for crypto enthusiasts and experts I
welcome feedback from where you know are
we barking up the wrong tree or not but
so far I've received extremely positive
feedback from the crypto community in
terms of tether being uh the the Highly
Questionable proposition the issue with
so many cryptocurrencies they're clearly
scams and there's that uh that that
Alameda woman Beckman Freed's girlfriend
who I think she said something like
crypto is just scams or something else
like it's like she's like it's all scams
and right something else or whatever and
like drugs or something crypto is I
think mostly scams but that's not uh to
disrespect crypto itself it's that well
everything's pretty much a scam these
days what isn't a scam yeah the issue is
that there are people who are using
crypto2 scam but there are absolutely
amazing and legitimate cryptocurrencies
and Technology itself is incredible so
we have the story from Bloomberg
U.S prosecutors opened probe of FTX
months before its collapse
Sweeping in pre-examine crypto exchanges
with offshore reach Manhattan
prosecutors recently changed Tac as FTX
unraveled so they knew about this
yeah how can they not this company came
out of nowhere and had all the huge
institutional money everyone was asking
the question where did they get all this
money and the corporate media in
response to this said he's the new JP
Morgan and Chase he's a genius and and
no one had the receipts no one knew what
was going on here and SPF was also given
hundreds of thousands of dollars to the
house committee members that are
investigating him I don't I don't see
this this going anywhere except for a
potential false flag being used here in
order to bring in more regulations bring
in more control of what essentially
would be a decentralized cryptocurrency
but now is going to be hyper focused to
be a central bank digital currency that
of course is going to be a part of the
Great reset and build back better agenda
which they've been calling for for a
very long time and this is the way this
is the false flag that they're going to
get it I don't know though I feel like
this stuff is shaking confidence in
crypto absolutely well if they want
people to adopt a reserve crypto this is
not the way a federal reserve
cryptocurrency a digital dollar is
essentially what they want they don't
everyone just on bitcoin they don't want
everyone on they don't want everyone on
decentralized platforms they want
everyone on their platforms so they
could say hey cryptocurrency was bad
because it was Reckless and they had
scams we have a bigger scam here the US
dollar for you that's going to be
getting the good principles from it and
we're not going to be doing the bad
principles even though we're we really
have all the best make every transaction
you ever have publicly available exactly
yeah people would not track that Trace
everything automatically take money out
of accounts like a social credit score
system like they have in China so this
is essentially the end game here and
Central Bank digital currencies are
something that's being rolled out with
the New York Federal Reserve just a
couple days ago and we're seeing this
with the G20 just announcing that
they're going to have an international
Health passport that they're going to
implement all over the world so when we
look at you know the scams in our
society there's a lot of them FTX is
just scratching the surface to all the
bigger scams out there and just
including perhaps tether and just as as
an addendum uh Alameda the
um hedge fund uh set up by Sam bankman
freed that's associated with the FDX
Scandal they were the major backer of
tether in fact they're one of the two
major uh purchasers of tether on their
exchange and so they're interesting
connections there as well looks like FTX
was kind of money laundering scheme to
filter through the sort of democrat
machine and the Clinton Overworld and
tether may be a kind of BCCI which is
used for sort of
um CIA Iran the new Iran Contra type
operations uh globally yeah that was an
interesting Saga the the BCCI Scandal
right
um can you expand on that just a little
bit because I think that's an important
history lesson that we should kind of
revisit especially when it comes to
understanding the largest part of the
the larger intelligence agencies and
their involvement with the big Banks and
how they actually work together to screw
you over right the reason these things
are important is that the the government
does not reinvent its own Playbook very
often at all and if there's an
historical antecedent that serves an
important function you can pretty much
bet that it still exists in some
modified version and so the fact that
the BCCI existed in the 70s and 80s
which is a bank set up by Pakistani
allegedly but it was probably set up by
an intelligence agency and it you know
major scam it screwed over its uh many
of its depositors it had a lot of shady
figures drug cartels arms dealers all
kinds of shady folks working through it
operating through it and then the
question was why was this manifest
obvious scam allowed to function for so
long uninterrupted well it's because the
CIA was in on it and the primary
beneficiary of it and so that gets to
the sort of crypto thing is like some
scams are allowed to exist because
they're of the scam of the most
valuable player so to speak and in a
kind of Darkly ironic twist that may in
fact end up being the Saving Grace of
tether and crypto more broadly is that
there are too many major scams wrapped
up into it that it's essentially too big
to fail at least on a medium timeline
yeah me and Tim were talking about this
earlier today if there was a way to
destroy cryptocurrencies in Bitcoin and
decentralized currencies what would they
be doing differently than what they're
doing right now and and I think it also
provided a huge potential and it still
might in many aspects of allowing people
to have a lot of freedom Barack Obama
called Bitcoin the ability of human
beings to have Swiss bank accounts
inside of their own Pockets I think that
that's a power that threatens a lot of
people and I think what we're seeing
with FTX what we're seeing with SBF is a
deliberate destruction of that power
right but you do you don't really have
that power if you're operating through
an exchange on an exchange absolutely
right yeah exchanges instead of also
honey pots as well exactly so like
they're two different things there's the
I guess and I don't mean this derisively
there's a the nerd money kind of
function of Bitcoin which is like you
have your own Keys you do all these but
it's a pain in the ass and people don't
really want to do it and it's not
Grandma friendly exactly but the
scalable version of Bitcoin
um is replete with all of these scams
and again maybe it's it's not going to
fall down precisely because the scams
are too valuable in the in the in the
specific case of tether potentially
being the new BCCI it's literally the
official cryptocurrency of the rohingo
Rebel group in Myanmar which is bizarre
that a rebel group would have an
official cryptocurrency but that's the
case
um it's beloved by the Syrian uh the the
Sunni moderates in Syria that John
McCain loves so much it's beloved by
cartels which of course the US
intelligence agencies don't have any
relationship with yeah it's not like
they help them get their start in Mexico
with that secret police unit that they
were training down there they had
nothing to do with that right wow come
on you guys I think it's a little over
the time it's like a little out there
it's like Obama was giving weapons
exactly it's not like we had the Iran
Contra Scandal that was laundering
weapons and heroin and and cocaine into
the country and guns and weapons it's
funny because you say that Meme where
it's like okay so look I know the CIA
was doing bad stuff in the 50s the 60s
the 70s the 80s the 90s the 2000s the
2010s but nothing's changed they've
never been out and never been held
accountable right so like so they're
definitely they definitely changed
they're definitely not doing that now
yep that's that's a new management yes
yeah and for and and you know the way
this country is going there's that
there's that uh viral video of the dude
in Arizona with the dreads and he's like
yelling about about box number three in
Arizona stuff oh that's a great video
and I'm just like I'm watching that
video and I'm thinking the average
person in this country does not like
what the intelligence agencies are doing
so who are they serving but themselves
now maybe these people have the idea
like well they don't know what's good
for them okay well dude like that defies
the core of what this country is
supposed to be it's supposed to be
dangerous Freedom not peaceful slavery
just you as an intelligence officer
whatever deciding you know what's best
for us you don't and clearly all of this
luxury has been bad for us it's created
a whole generation of gluttonous morons
so maybe maybe we need things to be a
little bit less luxurious and people
need to go out and chop some Lumber to
heat their homes maybe all of this
luxury is making weak people which makes
everything worse for everybody and all
we get is a bunch of whiny complainers
and um what are the young Elon call them
a hall monitors home monitors I said a
national Hall monitors yeah there's only
so much of an economy that you can make
being a homeowner but that's that's
really it those guys who are working
that oil rig we're watching that video a
moment ago those guys are doing hard
work the lady at Twitter Hall Monitor
Vice media Paul monitors BuzzFeed Hall
monitors NBC News Hall monitors all they
do they walk around complaining
contributing nothing yeah we got to do
something about that they're bogging us
down
I want to post jokes I know I want to
post memes yeah without being yeah
afraid of getting censored or or Express
political ideas or or debate political
ideas that might be a little edgy or
controversial I want to have the ability
to talk through bad ideas you know and
we we still let's be honest here we're
still testing the waters with Twitter we
still don't have that fully and that's
that's a shame because that's what we
had before and then we were LED astray
by the centralization of it all and now
the solution is going to be more
centralization which is absolutely
absurd you mean with Elon or what more
centralization as far as what's
happening with cryptocurrencies with
what's happening with uh social media
platforms being in the hands of less and
less people and uh you know media
Outlets being in control of less and
less people as well everything's being
centralized so weird like centralization
minus censorship really was sort of The
Sweet Spot because Central
centralization allowed speech at scale
so that brief period in the internet
when there were centralized platforms
major platforms
but before the speech Crackdown post
2016 was really kind of The Sweet Spot
and maybe it just can't sustain it maybe
the regime is simply incompatible with
that level of free speech at scale maybe
no regime is compatible but certainly
ours isn't given how
um how ridiculous and ultimately
untenable it is
um and so when they say that you know
Elon Musk is a national security threat
free speech is a national security
threat I think that's true in in quite a
literal sense is that if people are
allowed to speak freely on the whole
host of things that I'm you know not
even able to mention now
um that is I don't think the regime can
really survive it and so it's an
existential issue from their point of
view and that kind of illustrates the
stakes uh associated with what Elon Musk
is doing you know what you know what
really grinds my gears I hear this whole
time people will tweet something like
tell me one time in history when the
people censoring speech were the good
guys because it's just like World War II
the United States yeah were we the bad
guys I don't know like the US had an
office of censorship but it's it's like
people just assume outright that there's
that there's there's never a reason for
controlling information of course there
is like in in war and things like that
to your point the intelligence agencies
probably do think that you know we're in
a constitative conflict and we need to
be able to control information if we're
going to win but that can that conflicts
what this country is supposed to be
people having a right to choose if they
can't be informed they can't choose so
this country has clearly already lost if
that's the case but I will point out in
World War II with the office office of
censorship
loose lips sink ships and uh this was it
there were sensors who would stop things
from peering in newspapers in the radio
censorship all over the United States of
the federal office of censorship because
we're at War well you know there's
there's a logical approach to this
specifically when it comes to saying hey
there's all these troops moving in this
direction going here obviously you can't
allow that kind of information during
Warfare because it's going to give the
enemy the upper hand but but but treason
doesn't fall under Free Speech no but
it's but it's not that it's that someone
might be alike I work at a steel mill
and they just some crazy thing happened
where the alarm went off today that's
the kind of thing they don't they they
loose lip sync ships wasn't just about
telling people where our military was
some people didn't know that it was
about giving up information on on what
you were doing to people who shouldn't
know about it they wanted everyone to
shut up it's a fine line too because
we're we're you know where do you draw
the boundaries because you know in the
you know in the United States we did
have the Japanese internment camps we
did have the bombing of Dresden we do
have a lot of policies that we could
definitely criticize the United States
for which we should have criticized
which criticism could have prevented but
that didn't happen because of that
censorship effort as well so again where
do where's that fine line I think that's
impossible I don't know Darren do you
have an answer
well I think
um I think censorship and information
control are necessary to any type of
regime I think the important issue is if
the noble lie is necessary in in some
degree as you know the famous thing from
the Republic
uh the problem is that we become a the
ignoble lie and it's less that oh we
want a total you know free for all free
speech is that fundamentally what
America has come to represent what I
call the globalist American Empire is
really
um you know the wokeness or whatever you
want to call it really is basically the
um de facto official religion the de
facto official ideology of the United
States and once it's seeped that deeply
into the marrow of the body politic then
anything that's set up to sustain the
security of It ultimately just
reinforces that ideology that's the
problem that we're in
um and that's not
per se a problem of censorship as such
it's a problem of what the regime has
become in its most fundamental sense it
is a non-theistic religion it's crazy I
mean it's becoming more and more clear
every day Peter bogosian was talking
about it years ago and now we can see
we can see it clearer than ever
all right we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only show
coming up around 11 pm and I think we're
going to talk about some fashion company
with handbags or something is that what
it was yeah it was Balenciaga there you
go
controversial topic say the least and uh
you can also do one more thing follow
Sargon of akkad on Twitter because he's
back after like five years and um it's
Sargon underscore of underscore akad
akkad or just go to my Twitter at
timcast and I tweeted out that he's back
and you can follow him there he's
probably sleeping he's in the UK but I'm
really excited sorry Jordan he red
pilled me like when I was a little young
in like 14 15 years old Jordan Peterson
tweeted you know something like
surprised to see you here Sargon so
we're all excited that Carl Benjamin's
back on Twitter so uh give him a follow
all right let's see we got
K says please get the critical Drinker
on both timcast IRL as well as Pop
Culture crisis he's the best movie
critic and fighting the message from the
woke entertainment corporations yeah be
fine sounds good
oh this is funny this Sargon got
unbanned right before uh the show
started Neo unrealist says Sergeant
avocados unbanned from Twitter right
before show started yeah it was like 30
minutes before man yeah a lot of people
were tweeting about him and a lot of
other people as well I mean for him it's
been it's been five years it's like
watching you know the corpse come out of
the ground like when you're like he's
back yeah he's gonna dust off the phone
yeah right
yep I mean he's been doing his thing but
it'll it'll be cool to see him back in
the conversation yeah I just I just
watched uh part of his loaded series
program he did a thing about Millennials
and gen Z stuff and it was like the old
Sargon where he was just talking to and
sitting down and chatting which was cool
to see so it's funny he's back right now
it's great oh yeah all of our super
chats are Sargon unbanned Sargon
unbanned wow
William Nichols says your Shadow band I
recorded it for proof that's right this
show is and it is insane that despite
the fact that we are Shadow band uh you
guys still watch and it's it's it's
weird
I mean we're in a weird place this show
should be trending every night based on
how many views we get yeah never does
and maybe maybe not every single shot
I'm being a little hyperbolic but uh
never goes yeah yeah
all right
mind of madman says no notification and
I believe in Clank and beanie Supremacy
well all right no notification
how about that shout out clankers yup
Rob says Tim and Co I'm setting up a
ligma Johnson candle e-store thank you
for the inspiration another thing you've
inspired me to do and I look forward to
your order
you know what you're thinking of doing
is uh I tweeted out a piece of land in
West Virginia it's like 180 acres and I
was like this could be the ligma Johnson
Woodland preservation we could actually
like allocate plots of ownership you
know and you get a little hard fake
ligma Johnson Lords yeah
it's interesting because like the price
per square foot is actually not that
expensive and then you could you're not
really a lore we wouldn't do that but
you'd have like you know we could create
a public park and then it would be owned
by the people who own the square footage
and that could be a lot of people you're
an official ligma yeah yeah you gotta
you can be uh
I don't know what kind of title do we
give can't you still buy stuff by
Richard you could name a couple of stars
like Johnson who has the right to the
Stars that's a good point though you
couldn't find out eventually what if we
just like all of these programs like go
to a star buying company and then just
buy as many stars as possible and name
them all ligma Johnson and they'll start
giving them numbers like ligma Johnson
ligma Dixon
other ones will be segma uh what else uh
I can't think of other ones
tugma leave it in the chat y'all yeah
I know they know they are and they they
definitely have good uh okay thanks guys
all right DD Mega Dudu says hey Tim and
crew I would like to know if Luke's
luclier bazangas implants are still up
for grabs
yeah I'm asking you and wondering if she
followed through yeah I walk in and it's
on the floor and it's leaking all over
the place
you know I did mention it just for the
record but I I didn't actually ask
because they're dead you wanted you
wanted them first he wanted them we are
you were asking about them we are going
to uh be giving out those as well as the
posters for Milo I mentioned
we're we're bogged up because of the
holiday so a lot of people are already
heading out getting ready for
Thanksgiving some people have to travel
I'm not even sure if we're going to be
able to do our Wednesday show because
everyone's traveling to Thanksgiving
dinner nobody wants to drive on
Thanksgiving morning so
we'll just have to figure it out but
that also means that like No One's Gonna
be here so this is just one of those
weeks where very little ends up
happening you got to get the chicken in
here
I'm not bringing a chicken everyone
keeps trying to get me to bring the
chicken in here she's gonna take a dump
on the floor look I love the chickens
clearly Roberto Jr is a man's man you
know he's tough but he will take a dump
on the floor and how are you gonna get
that out of the carpet you can get a
steam cleaner in here and you know it's
fine it's worth it
Mary will you be here
I say do the show I need something to
watch wait for Wednesday or for episode
666 Wednesday
uh which would be episode six no no if
there is Wednesday if if we do the show
on Wednesday Monday will be 666 if we
don't then Tuesday will be 666. I think
you should leave Monday for 666. why
Monday why it's better than doing it you
just don't want to work see women don't
want to work no no she's saying we
should do the Wednesday show but the
issue is I don't know if we have anybody
here
yeah and that yeah it's
I mean I don't like taking shows off but
there's all like Ian and Luke are going
to be gone yeah and so you know
could just have you monologue like the
old days we just turn the camera on and
eat turkey and you can watch us eat
turkey
Bring it on Bring on a member of the
members area well I mean I think Mary
you're here yeah yeah so Hannah Montana
she's also here we can grab a couple
people but if we don't do the show that
means Tuesday 666 and we have an awesome
guest on Tuesday which I'm excited about
having for 666. that'd be worth it I
think save it but that means like I
don't like doing not working for three
days because it made me lose my mind
[Music]
what's happening
need to talk about stuff
and I'll start I'll start talking to the
cat I'll be like Buckle let me explain
to you what's going on you could have
them no no like I'll start monologuing
to him like I need to tell someone I'll
look into his eyes and it'll travel into
into hell and then all the demons will
be watching
all right let's read some more
all right Bobby says elon's remarks on
Alex Jones are inexcusable let's stop
acting like Elon fanboys
you know that there there's the question
there right
take the win I agree with you on Alex
Jones I I think it's it's BS and and
Darren said the same thing he should not
have gone there he should not have said
it what are you gonna do are we gonna be
like well let's forgo the entire Victor
we have on all of these things Sargon
being back on Twitter of all people you
know nah I'll take the win I'll take the
win I will let Elon know I I find his
statements incorrect uh morally uh wrong
and objectionable and then what are you
gonna do you know we're better off I
mean he's accusing Alex Jones of
weaponizing the death and Trauma of
children and their families yet he
himself is using his own trauma of the
death of his child as as a bludgeon well
I guess
you know I understand what he's saying
right he's like Alex Jones exploited
this he suffered it you know what I mean
and but but either way it's just it's a
it's an emotional thing
I just don't agree Raymond g Stanley Jr
says me tell me you're from the city
without telling me you're from the city
Tim a man can kill a bear by jamming his
arm down a bear's throat I didn't mean
that literally Raymond I was joking I
made a point early where I was like if a
guy's gonna go fight a bear and kill him
with his own hands by like punching him
in the throat and holding his arm
causing the bear to choke and then
killing it I didn't literally mean
someone would do that my point was that
a man is not going to defeat a bear with
his bare hands like there are some
stories with it happening but it's never
like a Grizzly or anything no it's
always a black bear I'm talking about
the point I was trying to make is the
grand story of the man of David versus
Goliath is pointless if there's no
family like a dude does not need to kill
the the emperor stag of the forest that
weighs hundreds of you know thousands of
pounds or whatever because what is he
gonna do with it he's going to be like
well it's dead no like the conquest is
always in support or saving of someone
else so he might he might be revitalized
to code for another few hours if there's
an attractive woman working in the HR
department I think that's true actually
like how I'd be willing to bet that that
if you
I think this is fairly obvious Okay then
if you take two guys and ask them to you
know work out and we're gonna track how
many reps they can do until they have to
stop
I bet if you took two guys and put them
in a gym and said do as many lifts as
you can until your arms are too sore to
move if you then brought a woman in a
very attractive one they'd probably
start lifting again they'd like they'd
find that but for real though a second
wind and it's it's not a statement on
like magic or anything the statement on
just what human beings are the guy's
gonna be like I'm gonna do it you know
like give him a reason give him a
physical reason more importantly I've
read those stories about women who have
lifted cars off of their kids oh yeah
yeah like we know that humans do things
for other humans this is the way that's
cool actually
reading a story like a kid got hit by a
car and the mom she's like five five she
like lifts the car up like tears her
muscles but she doesn't care she's like
I will save you out yeah should they
compress lip like vertebrae in her back
right it was like crazy story like that
yeah I I remember watching a story about
a guy who got crushed by a boulder and
then he lifted the boulder off of him
and it was like it was like 700 I don't
know how heavy it was but doing so tore
his muscles he like put so much strain
into doing it and they were saying like
your muscles actually have
five times more reluctant capacity but
they destroy themselves in doing it so
that's why they're like limited so you
know we're actually pretty strong
humorous stronger than we know
everybody was super chatting Carla's
back on on Twitter I'm glad we didn't
notice because we made a lot of money
off people trying to tell us but thank
you for the super chats I appreciate it
I'm stoked to see Carl on man I'm really
excited for that it's great he's he's
amazing Lotus Eaters podcast is
fantastic yeah it is
Biko says is timcast interested in
hiring pop culture writers if so what
would be the best way to apply I don't
know and I don't know I guess Mary's in
charge of that
yeah I'm in charge DM me on Twitter
there you go
yeah you know she's on pop culture
crisis that's their that's their purview
all right AK storm says Tim please ask
Mary about the BDSM teddy bears marketed
to children she covered on pop culture
crisis today truly disturbing we'll talk
about that yeah we'll talk about the
after show go off yeah we'll make it
we'll we'll get we'll get right into it
that'll be really really good
all right pinochet's helicopter tour
says well Tim Google really didn't like
your four o'clock video and I can
confirm it I saw that and I was like oh
what does that mean well the good news
is the video I put up at 4 pm is that
the Arizona assistant AG is refusing to
certify the election this is true it's
it's in the news it's happening it is uh
it's doing really well people are able
to get it but it is demonetized so uh
there you go which means I'll make
probably
I don't know
20 bucks off of uh that video for the
day so oh you know it is what it is I'll
take 20 bucks you know what I mean but
that's that's that's like erasing the
revenue off of it you know you're making
20 bucks I want 20 bucks I'm not even
getting that this is why we shifted
Focus to doing uh Tim cast memberships
for the company because you've got
activists trying to take your ads away
and because YouTube's trying to take
your ads away so I also this is this is
this is a thing too I've picked up uh
which I started doing established titles
sponsorship on the timcast channel I
normally don't do ad reads on because
they're demonetizing everything so I'm
like okay let's play that game
demonetized shadow man whatever people
who want to watch my content are going
to watch it I'm I'll sell my own ad if
you're not going to run ads against it
and so that makes up the difference so
we will we will always find a way we're
not going to let censorship get us down
the one free man says odd how All Tech
platforms laying off thousands of people
in unison Elon said Twitter was
hemorrhaging 4 million dollars a day
what was keeping them afloat until Elon
burst the bubble was someone subsidizing
them in exchange for censorship
no it's that a bunch of advertisers
pulled off the platform when Elon moved
in because they're biased lunatics and
so then they start losing money however
I do think something interesting is
happening in in terms of all these
layoffs because we're seeing a bunch of
AD buyers say that there's like they're
cutting down on sponsorships and
marketing firms are saying there's less
money to go around so
the reporting that I heard is that next
year there's going to be a major
economic downturn
uh where'd you hear that I just just got
about on Twitter you know yeah I I saw
that really funny uh Twitter account it
was uh inverse Kramer you ever see that
one
oh yeah whatever Jim Cramer says do the
opposite yeah and then they show
everything he was wrong about and
they're like if you do the opposite of
what he says you get rich yeah it's like
uh uh inverse Kramer is like George
Costanza when he decided to do
everything opposite
Phoenix ammunition says we've sent
several appeals to Twitter to be
reinstated and so far nothing we never
actually broke a rule in the first place
Elon please help y'all guys should tweet
about Phoenix ammunition because they
were unjustly banned from Twitter were
they yeah they're they're cool guys yeah
yeah
they're the ones who did the website
where when you wanted to buy ammo it
asked you if you voted for Joe Biden and
if you put yes it kicks you out of the
website I think it set you to like um
his gun control page or something
he's like we don't need your money
that's a phoenix with an f-e-n-i yeah
f-e-n-x good guys Fire Burns people says
want to start watching Tim cast iron
tonight and was not in my subscription
tab or on the channel page found found
it on my home page under the live tab
isn't that something uh and that's
something huh that was that this the
same thing happened to me I was going on
my phone to the channel and I couldn't
find it yeah it happens a lot yeah man I
got to tell you if you guys didn't like
watching the show like it we would have
been annihilated by YouTube censorship a
long time ago yeah there if if we were
if we were like Lex Friedman as Darren
described it we're the we're the inverse
of Lex Friedman like the way he
describes it is people are just
stumbling maybe that's what YouTube's
doing they're like get everybody to
watch everybody who watches Tim cast
iron go watch Lex Freeman instead so
we're getting punished in the algorithm
but people are like YouTube stop I want
to watch this show and then meanwhile
people are waking up and they're
watching Lex well that's I don't know if
that's actually true
speculation no it's nothing against Lex
but they're they're working
conversations that that our friend Susan
uh of of YouTube
was having and basically people were
criticizing her for not doing a full-on
ban of Ben Shapiro and her defense of
that was saying that we've run a lot of
studies on it and they've shown that Ben
Shapiro is actually a very effective
stopping point that is to say he serves
a very important de-radicalization
function and for that reason I think
um you know there's a real utility to
the Susan Wozniak or whatever which is
oh Jackie wojinski
whoa Jack Susan but uh there's a real
utility to the uh to the sensors say
that look these people are an off-ramp
they're de-radicalizers they'll go and
they'll watch Lex Friedman and in many
cases
and again nothing against these people
personally but there is a kind of Fool's
trade whereby a certain type of talking
head will earn your trust by saying
controversial things like boys have
penises and girls have vaginas and in
exchange for that trust will shove down
orthodoxies on everything else down your
throat and that is a very important
deradicalization effort and there's a
cluster of people who may fit that
description and I think it's fair to say
that
um
The Lex phenomenon may be adjacent to
to all of that or Ben Shapiro you know
telling people to take medical
procedures
um also Ben Shapiro gets a lot of his
traffic from Facebook overwhelmingly
well he has the daily wire I've yeah
I've heard if you look at the number one
shared kind of articles on Facebook it's
usually daily wire no it's again daily
daily wire is the Lex Friedman of
Facebook
and and it's not accidental I I've heard
I'm not going to say for a fact but I've
heard on good authority Shapiro has a
great relationship with Zuckerberg and
they've had the great relationship for a
long time and again it's there's a
utility to having Ben Shapiro who's very
reliable on the key things being
basically as right-wing as you can be
and not punished by the algorithms right
there's a utility to that in terms of
how the larger conversation is
controlled well speaking of that we've
got Chris toast who says show is hidden
from my feed on both Android and desktop
oh that's amazing then we have uh what
is this right here
Sergeant wolf says hey Tim and crew I'd
figure I figured I'd chat and let you
know that the show was not in my feed
not on my home screen or subscribed
uploaded feed had to go to the channel
and find it there yeah really
interesting it's we're getting more
messages than normal so
share the URL on every single platform
Twitter how about that post it to
Twitter where you're allowed to make
jokes again
and uh hopefully the the hope I have is
that if enough people who watch this
video share the URL every time it goes
live no amount of censorship will stop a
natural phenomenon of people saying
check this show out because clearly
they're trying to stop us
you know part of me is like oh you know
what if we finally get banned I can go
take my van down by the river and go
fishing not have to worry about it but
you know for the time being we're here
to fight the culture war and it looks
like we're winning so they're gonna
there's gonna be the death rattle
there's gonna be the the the panic
attacks YouTube's gonna lose its mind
they're not happy about it the reason
why say Elon Musk buys Twitter the
reason why these changes are happening
is because we have not stopped pushing
back and demanding Free Speech calling
out the lies in the machine and they
wish we would just roll over so
it's a little thing we can do but I say
the same thing of Stephen Crowder you
know they they they they keep giving
them strikes on YouTube watch his show
on Rumble watch Lotus Eaters watch the
quartering and then just share all the
contents the most powerful thing you can
do they can't censor it if everyone just
keeps sharing it's like whack-a-mole
they can't do anything about it I think
that's one of the reasons I still exist
you know dealing with all the crap I
think it's viral marketing we don't even
do any regular marketing it's you guys
sharing the the videos
yeah they they YouTube's not
recommending us yeah YouTube recommends
our videos to only people who are
already in that bubble people still tell
me they get unsubscribed from the
channel when they never unsubscribed so
again lots of crazy things happening
here
the ass says Hey Lucas I bought a shirt
from your website never got a return
email I messaged you via Instagram so
help me out also love the work that you
all do yeah you should be able to
message the company that you bought it
from and they'll send you a tracking
number you should if you have any
problems also if you have any sometimes
you know rarely this happens I get a
message someone saying that the graphics
weren't that well you could get a new
t-shirt right away after emailing the
company that of course did all the
processing so if you have any problems
with quality or shipping reach out to
either Teespring or another company we
work with and they usually solve all
your problems right away Ian Kenny says
Kanye was hanging out with Milo
yiannopoulos said he's running for
president in 2024 and Milo will be his
campaign manager yeah I saw that is that
true I saw the video There's an actual
video of a random guy filming outside
and Connie's like Yay he's like hey
coming inside and he's like he's Milo's
there and and that's what Kanye said
he's running what yay said yeah uh yay
24. all right
okay let's see what is this one
uh attacked tacti platy says Tim Mary is
a far better co-host than Ian for this
show as well not cringe half the time
and doesn't say upsetting things please
what does Ian say that upsets you so
much hey Mary's great but so is Ian Ian
I think adds another component to the
show that that is very rare and is
awesome and I think is needed yeah
pissing people off upsetting them well I
think he's he needs people need to do
that people like it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be a circle you know what a
circle of of jerks yeah Pat each other
on the back yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
not here for that we heard it we're we
want to hear uh you know opinions that
are not ours and Ian provides that and
he allows us to have conversations or if
that's what you want yeah sure no but
he's being real he's being you know I
believe he's being genuine there's
there's several instances where Ian has
brought up very bad points and also
wears brought up very good points when
we were talking about the lockdowns and
stuff and why we didn't think the
government should be able to lock things
down he said what about an air born
Ebola like where's the line and I was
like okay like let's entertain like
let's talk about that because we're all
very much opposed to government
lockdowns but then and then we sort
those things through if if we all just
agree with each other your ideas aren't
strengthened yeah like you you actually
need someone to contradict even if it's
not always a good argument but the other
thing too is
uh well I guess that's it it's simply
put right yeah you you need some kind of
uh challenge but I'll add one more thing
to it some people comment they're like
Ian doesn't know about this stuff why is
he on the show and it's like that was
always the the reason why I asked Ian to
be on the show I was like we need
someone who's going to be like what is
that I don't know what that is yeah so
to give us an opportunity to explain it
because when we started the show I
didn't I I assumed most people would not
have the Deep political knowledge that
we do and and we don't know everything
either but the point was to have someone
who's going to be like what do you mean
Joe Biden did that oh let me explain
because the assumption is if Ian who's
not overtly political doesn't know
there's a lot of people at home who
don't and we want to make it more
accessible but again Ian in those
semantic arguments Ian come on buddy
semantic arguments they don't go
anywhere you guys are both great we did
a a live show and then you know we had
like Ian was there we were jamming and
then someone asked something about Ian
then now and then I said you know Ian
comes up with really great points a
bunch often we often disagree but those
semantic arguments and then everyone in
the crowd started clapping and cheering
and then Ian was laughing I probably
disagree with Ian about 99 of things
yeah but everyone in the chat knows Ian
Rose 20s it happens yeah he's pro-death
penalty and he's pro-choice yeah why and
pro acid it's like a weird combination
of things you know like typically
liberals like I'm not saying it's a
liberal but Liberals are like anti-death
penalty pro-choice but Ian's pro-choice
and protest he's consistent there yeah
right you know it's all right man yeah
all right let's see uh Fair Frozen says
the men are covered in hydraulic mud a
liquid prepared with soil water and
glycol and other aggregates
used to inject into the drill it acts as
a barrier between gas escaping from the
well tap oh that's right I remember that
interesting yeah
yeah
all right Noah Zork says are there
non-farting rooms
we should set up a fart booth in the
basement and it's just like if you have
to fart you got to go in the booth
that'd be hilarious and it's just got
like an air freshener like like fan
going
we'll call it the fart booth most air
fresheners are scams
um what does that mean do they give you
cancer or something they like mess up
your uh your interesting system yeah
I've heard them before they're horrible
every time we see it just trash right
away especially those little uh those
little trees I think those are the ones
especially like for Breeze and all these
other stuff horrible for you absolutely
destroys like your physical body so what
is this uh
says Apple deleted all their tweets and
pulled ads head of the App Store deleted
their account they might pull the
Twitter app this says Elon finally
removes exploitation from the platform
uh yeah that Apple really remove all
their tweets before c UE jobs uh died I
know that they I know Apple was yeah
apples are content good about
preventing child exploitation on the
apps on the App Store wow but then ever
since then it's been less enforced
Hermes bird says this guest sounds
exactly like DeSantis it's uncanny do
people tell you that Darren that you
sound like Ron DeSantis I've never heard
that before some some when I saw that I
was like yeah a little bit like I can
hear something
aren't you in Florida right now Miami oh
yeah we're talking about for the show
that's correct I think they just mean
I'm very tired ah yes that explains it
people are mentioning Balenciaga is that
what it's called Balenciaga Balenciaga
there you go there you go is it see your
Chi what I think in Italian the sea is a
chair sound right it's not an Italian
brand it's it was founded by a Spanish
man and it's headquartered in France
so so if it's French then it's probably
just it's not it's not French though
it's Spanish have you ever seen that
viral video about the French language
where it's like
yeah because they were like all these
words are the same thing it's like
they all mean something different
it's like okay I guess it's just a
tongue twister though you know what I
mean like we have those in English we do
we have the same yeah
Reina uh Rhino bada says
it's an Afrikaans name oh there you go
he says good morning from South Africa
where I always find your shows in my
feed hey that's cool interesting what's
up
Jason Lippert says I'm in Canada have no
issues finding show do you need a tissue
there do you speak do you speak
Afrikaans I do to the most but my
parents will say I don't but oh really
yeah what is it like Dutch and English
and London it's basically Dutch uh it's
like more like Old Dutch because we
didn't get uh influence from like the
Spanish taking over Holland and then you
know creating the masculine feminine in
Dutch now but essentially it's like Old
Dutch yeah oh wow a little known well
how about that
all right Nate B says how do you know
you aren't a stopping point Tim I think
we are I agree talked about this too I
I've been saying for a while that the
reason uh YouTube probably tolerates us
more than other shows is because they
view us as a d radical deradicalization
force or something or or the way I put
it is
YouTube wants to ban the right but they
know that if they do the right will go
somewhere else so they need to allow
certain channels to stand the platform
so that if they ban so if they ban half
of them the users will stay and then
they force them into a into this
particular ideological bubble
I've long talked about that it's not
going to change my opinions on things I
guess but I will say this smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends become
a member at timcast.com because we're
going to talk about this creepy story
with the was it Balenciaga yeah
Balenciaga Balenciaga BDSM teddy bears
in their new ad campaign children and
court documents pertaining to child
exploitation really weird we'll talk
about that over at timcast.com so become
a member we're gonna start we usually
start recording right after we wrap and
then we we upload as soon as we're done
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me at timcast uh smash
the like button and Darren do you want
to shout anything out
revolver.news check it out very very hot
tether piece the next FTX but bigger a
lot of people are talking about it and
so check it out are you on Twitter I am
on Twitter at darrenjbeaty
you can find pictures of me on Instagram
at maryarchived you can read my inane
thoughts on Twitter also at Mary
archives
um and you can subscribe to pop culture
crisis on YouTube if you're interested
in us talking about entertainment
celebrities movies
Etc over there not not political but
more fun so go subscribe over there when
you when you super chat a pop culture
crisis money guns fire money into the
air yeah it doesn't phase me anymore
like I I just barely even notice it but
it scares the guests a lot that's cool
that's great shell shocked
this is awesome thank you so much for
coming I always appreciate when you're
on uh my YouTube channel is youtube.com
forward slash we are change I'm getting
absolutely screwed over there but I do
work very hard I just got a new video
out there about all the craziness in the
world uh we are changed on YouTube and
uh uh Elon Musk is promising a video
platform on Twitter uh Luke we are
change at on Twitter
see you guys next time we need a tissue
first we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out
cheers